next A batteries included framework for
building any type of web application you
can imagine with vue.js the purpose of
VJs is to build front-end user
interfaces with JavaScript but a true
full stack web application also needs to
deal with routing data fetching caching
deployment and more that's where nux
comes in it works by strapping its Nitro
server engine to view enabling multiple
rendering modes from a single
application by default it does Universal
rendering where the initial page view is
rendered on the server then JavaScript
takes over to handle all subsequent
navigation client-side however if that's
not ideal developers can set different
rendering and caching rules for every
route and it's capable of running on
edge networks like cloudflare its
built-in Dev tools are incredible and
may trigger jealousy if you use a
different framework beyond that it has a
huge ecosystem of modules that can
handle requirements like image
optimization content management database
Integrations e-commerce and countless
others to get started generate a new
project with the CLI then you'll find
the main entry point in the app.view
file and notice how it's configured with
typescript out of the box to an ensure
your own safety to build an application
you write view components in the Pages
directory the structure of the file
system determines the routes and URLs in
the browser what's unique about nux
though is that reusable components and
composables have their own dedicated
directories any code defined here can be
automatically imported in your pages and
that means you don't need a massive list
of import statements in every single
page and under the hood it will
automatically handle code splitting so
only the JavaScript needed for the
components in this file will be sent
Downstream to the browser next up we
have the layouts directory here we
Define view components that have a slot
in the middle allowing the outer UI like
a nav bar and footer to be shared across
multiple Pages now if you're building a
Blog you'll really like the content
directory because here you can write
content and markdown and use it
throughout the application with minimal
friction then we have the middleware
directory which is capable of running
code before you navigate to a route like
for collecting analytics or checking the
user authentication state next has many
other special directories to offer but
everything in the framework is
progressively enhanced which means you
can opt into these features as needed
now when it comes to data fetching it
has built-in composables like use fetch
it's built on top of the fetch API in
the browser but can also cache and
dedupe requests to make your application
more efficient with zero effort on top
of that it also provides a use state
composable that can deal with the
complex issue of State Management
between client and server renders when
it comes to search engine optimization
it also provides composables like use
head and use SEO meta to easily add
metadata for search Bots meanwhile for
humans you can easily animate page
transitions with the built-in transition
component and finally when it comes time
to deploy you can either pre-render for
a static host build it for a node.js
server or deploy it to a serverless edge
function this has been nuxed in 100
seconds it's been a while since I've
made one of these videos If you think I
should continue making videos like this
hit the like button and let me know in
the comments thanks for watching and I
will see you in the next one
[Music]